العنصريه وصلت الى الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا
صحيح فتخيلوا ان جهازا يعمل بهذه التقنيه
اضر عمدا بصحه مرضى بسبب لون بشرتهم حقيقه
مرعبه لكن كيف تم ذلك تقرير لصحيفه
الجارديان يقولوا ان جهاز قياس التاكسد
النبطي اعطى نتائج خاطئه اثناء فحصه
لمستويات الاكسجين في الدم لدى مرضى من
ذوي البشره السمراء ما ادى الى علاجهم
بشكل غير صحيح ما ذكرته هنا يعد مثالا
واحدا من امثله اشار اليها خبراء يحذرون
من خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي وقدرته على
الاضرار بملايين البشر عبر التشخيص الخاطئ
لامراض اشخاص معينين او استخدام معلوماتهم
الخاصه بشكل غير دقيق عبر اضافه بيانات او
حذفها من سجلهم الطبي ومع كل ذلك لا شك ان
هناك قدره هائله للذكاء الاصطناعي في
تحسين تشخيص الامراض وايجاد طرق افضل
للعلاج